The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Can everyone hear me?
So I guess it's 2:35, and we
might as well get started.
So the calendar, I think, still
says that we have a
guest lecture today but sorry to
disappoint you, there is no
guest lecture.
Instead we have a quiz for
you on Thursday, which is
so much more fun.
Not really.
But I do realize that everybody
has a lot to do,
even just for this class.
You guys have your final
project and so on.
So hopefully this
will be helpful.
It won't take the entire 1 and
1/2 hours, I don't think.
And the remaining time will be
up in office hours, answering
questions about stuff.
So the first thing is I decided
to run some stats that
we haven't run before
for this class.
These are your Project 42
4.2 final submissions.
And in the red are your beta
submission run times.
And in the blue are your
corresponding final
submission run times.
I thought it was just
interesting to see some groups
did massive improvements, while
others didn't really
change their programs much.
And just to give you an idea,
a 90% for your performance
grade is indicated by that
green line and below.
So the majority of the class
did really well.
All right.
So the thing that everybody's
concerned about.
So Quiz 2 will be in lecture
on Thursday.
It'll be an 80 minute quiz,
similar in format to the
previous one.
And you guys once again are
allowed a one-page handwritten
crib sheet.
And it covers everything that
has been done since Quiz 1.
It's not designed to be
cumulative, but unfortunately
due to the nature of the class,
there's going to be
some things from the previous
part of the class that you
would need to know or it would
be helpful to know.
Unlike last time, we didn't
post a practice quiz on
Stellar, because it turns out
that the material and the
order of the material gets
shuffled around quite a bit
every year.
And we have different focuses.
So posting a practice quiz would
actually be pretty mean,
because it would cause
you guys to study the
wrong things instead.
Instead I try to extract the
most useful things from our
discussions of what the quiz
is going to be this time.
So hopefully all this
information is helpful.
Feel free to interrupt
me at any
time if you have questions.
So the first part, I would
roughly call analyzing and
possibly writing parallel
programs.
And to start off, is everybody
familiar with what one of
these graphs represents?
So you have work and then
each circle is a
unit amount of work.
And then the graph shows the
dependencies of the things.
So just to start off with a
really simple question, what
is the total amount of
work represented?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: Uh oh.
I heard 17, which is not what I
got when I counted this last
night at 2:00.
AUDIENCE: 26.
AUDIENCE: 24.
PROFESSOR: I like 24.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: And I'm going to
assume it's 24, and not
embarrass myself by trying
to count it.
Now what is the span?
AUDIENCE: 8.
PROFESSOR: 8 sounds right.
So the longest path-- there's
actually a couple different
paths that end up being 8, but
I think 8's the right answer.
So then parallelism?
AUDIENCE: 3.
PROFESSOR: Cool.
All right.
So now that we're done with
that, how about a little bit
of background on caches.
So when you run programs in
parallel, it causes some more
interesting things to happen in
cache that did not happen
with serial execution.
One of those things
is true sharing--
cache misses-- which are
caused when multiple
processors, like multiple
threads, are trying to operate
on the same piece of
data in memory.
So as a result, your cache would
be forced to synchronize
that cache line and
move it across--
copy it from the freshest
processor to the other ones
every time that it's
requested.
And you end up with a lot
of overhead generated by
continually doing
these copies.
So ideally you don't
want to do this.
But it's a lot easier
said than done.
False sharing is a little bit
trickier because it's not
immediately apparent from
looking at your program that
you're having multiple
threads do the--
operate on the same data.
Instead with false sharing, you
have multiple processors
that want to operate on
different locations in memory.
But due to the way that your
computer's cache is organized,
they just happen to be in
the same cache line.
As a result, you end up with
the same memory, the same
overhead, that you would
see with true sharing.
But when you look at the code
itself, you don't think that
you're doing anything that
involves multiple threads
operating on the same data.
And so with that, here's
a piece of code.
And my question is this true
sharing or false sharing?
Let's take a vote.
How many people think
it's true sharing?
Nobody.
Well, how many people think
it's false sharing?
Come on.
You have to vote one
way or another.
Let's try this again.
True sharing?
False sharing?
That's better.
All right, so it is indeed
false sharing.
And can someone propose
a solution to fix it?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Separate A
and B, and put them
in different shelves.
PROFESSOR: Would that
be sufficient?
Putting them in different
trucks?
AUDIENCE: Then, padding
the trucks.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Maybe with a little
bit of padding,
depending on your system.
But sure, I'll accept that.
But on the quiz, you might be
asked to propose solutions to
problems that you find.
And hopefully those
will be easier.
Now on to a more fun topic--
synchronization.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
on sharing.
So if two programs only access
data, does that still count ?
PROFESSOR: If you only access
the data and nothing in the
cache line is being modified,
then you're safe, because
every processor can
independently read from their
own copy of that.
AUDIENCE: So that
doesn't count.
PROFESSOR: That doesn't
count, correct.
But the problem is if your cache
line is 64 kilobytes,
and any thread on any processor
changes one piece of
data inside that cache,
then everybody
has to pull new copies.
So the classic example to
demonstrate synchronization
correctness is the dining
philosophers problem, where
you have n--
I believe five in this case--
philosophers, and
five chopsticks.
And each philosopher
has to eat.
So they use mutexes to--
well, generally you need--
each philosopher's code would be
pick up two chopsticks and
then eat and then put down
their two chopsticks.
It's somewhat of a contrived
example, but it actually comes
up in a lot of cases.
And one of the cases where it
comes up is in the system that
I use to grade your
unit tests.
So I got impatient about
running 200 or so
unit test in series.
And since I had about 200 cores
altogether on the cloud
machines, I figured, why not
do them in parallel?
But the problem is I need to
run-- if I have students A and
B, I need to run student A's
test against student B's
implementation.
So the rough way that I did that
was I grabbed a lock on
student A's repository, grabbed
a lock on student B's
repository, and then
modified--
swapped in their test files, did
all my testing, and then
returned the files to the
original conditions, and then
let go of the locks.
Unfortunately, when you do that,
you run into much of the
same problem as the dining
philosophers problems.
So the naive strategy is for
each philosopher, you grab a
lock on your left chopstick.
You grab a lock on your right
one, with respect to you.
And then you eat and then you
unlock them in the same order.
So this has a bug.
Can anyone point
out what it is?
AUDIENCE: You want to unlock
in a certain order.
PROFESSOR: Actually, it doesn't
matter which order you
unlock in in in this case.
So bad things happen if
everybody starts at
the exact same time.
So everybody grabs their left
chopstick. there's five
people, five chopsticks,
so that works fine.
Now everybody wants to
grab their right one,
but it's not there.
Because the person to the right
already grabbed it as
their left.
So they wait forever for the
right chopstick to appear and
it never does.
So the situation is
called a deadlock.
And it's obvious to spot,
because all of your threads
are going to be stuck doing
absolutely nothing.
Your CPU is not doing
anything.
And you're just sitting there.
So a very common work-around
that people like for this is
to use what's called
a try lock pattern.
So what you do is you grab a
lock on one of them, like,
say, your left one.
And then for the right one,
instead of directly going and
trying to grab the
lock, you ask--
you basically do--
if the thing is unlocked,
grab it.
Otherwise, don't grab it.
So it's a non-blocking
approach to
trying to get a lock.
So it either succeeds and
you have the lock, or
it instantly fails.
And if it fails, then you switch
the order of which--
you put down the chopstick that
you grabbed, and then you
try the next one.
Maybe you wait a little
bit before then.
This is more or less than what
I did for your beta test, for
your unit test tester.
When it fails to--
if first grabs one student's
directory's locks.
And then it tries to grab
the second one.
If that fails, then it puts down
both locks, and then it
waits a little bit, and
then it tries again.
So what's the problem
with this approach?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It can
still hold up.
PROFESSOR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: It can keep waiting
and grabbing, and sometimes it
will contend.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, pretty much,
the same problem happens.
Only now you have the case where
everybody grabs their
left, and now the right
one's gone.
So they put down
their left one.
And then they all go to
grab the right one.
Now they have the right
one, and now they
want the left one.
But the left one not there.
So in theory, they can end
up doing this for a
very, very long time.
But in practice what happens
is because of scheduling
overhead, and the phase of the
moon and whatever else affects
computing, you'll end up after
a while, this become distinct
from this pattern and eventually
all the locks go
through, and you're OK.
But in the meantime, you spent a
lot of time spinning, trying
to grab locks.
And so this situation is
called a livelock.
And it's a lot more
annoying than a
deadlock because it happens--
it tends to be less
reproducible.
And it's harder to diagnose,
because if you're looking at
top or your favorite CPU
monitor, you see that the
program seems to be
making progress.
Maybe some of them actually get
the lock and go through.
But the rest of them don't.
So it's hard to argue
whether or not
there's correctness issue.
Now there's various classes
of solutions to the dining
philosophers problem, but you
guys can go look that up.
I'm not going to go over them.
So another issue with
synchronization is suppose you
have two threads.
Let's say this is a Mars Rover,
and it's on Mars.
And the two things that the
programmer wanted to do are
send back its debugging log, so
that the nerdier people at
NASA, I suppose, can read
them over, or whatever
they do with logs.
And the high priority, what
everybody actually wants, is
for the Rover to send
back pictures.
Now both of these things require
access to the radio
that's supposed to transfer
something.
And only one thing can
transmit at time.
Otherwise, the transmission
is garbled.
So a reasonable approach might
be to just lock the radio in
each thread before you transmit,
and then unlock
after you transmit.
So what could be a potential
issue with this?
AUDIENCE: One might
get all the time.
PROFESSOR: Let's say, the
scheduler interrupts every 10
milliseconds, and then 1 out of
the 10 times, it allows 10
logs to run.
And then 9 out of the 10 times,
it will allow some
pictures to run.
So everybody gets
time scheduled.
So I guess the easiest way to
illustrate this is what
happens if it's currently
running said logs, and it
grabs this lock.
And then while it's
transmitting, let's say on the
second megabyte, the scheduler
says your time is up.
And then it swaps in this
program, and it tries to run.
So now when this program runs,
it tries to lock the radio,
but the radio's already
locked.
And the one that locked
the radio is
the send locks thread.
And so it could sit there and
spin for a while waiting for
the lock to be available.
But that's not going
to happen.
Because the guy that's holding
the lock is a bug.
So in general, this is called
starvation, where in the
process of having a shared
resource, you end up unfairly
depriving someone else of
a resource when you're
not truly using it.
Well, I guess that's not the--
I guess you are using it, but
you're using it for longer
than is fair for you.
Like in the scheduler you wanted
90% to one process and
10% to the other, but in reality
you end up with a
completely different
set of priorities.
And this inversion of priorities
is commonly called
priority inversion.
Does that make sense?
Cool.
So on a completely
different topic.
So Cilk hyperobjects
were covered
extensively in lecture.
You guys had a problem set on
it, although it was not
received very warmly from
what I see in the
problems sets write ups.
But I think all of the basic
material for what a Cilk
hyperobjects is and what it
does can be found in the
lecture material.
But more interesting, let's
explore what you can do with
hyperobjects that aren't
in the documentation.
So I'm going to define
a piece of code here.
And it's C++ or Cilk++ code.
And the first part of it
defines a very simple
structure called a point.
And it has three members.
Or actually it has two members,
x and y, and it has
three methods for setting the
values of x and y and also
getting the values of x and y.
Question?
No?
OK.
And then there's also a
hyperpoint class which
contains some extra Cilk junk.
And it also implements the
same three methods.
Set, get x, and get y.
And if you look at the monoid
that it contains the point
monoid it implements a
reduce function that
just doesn't do anything.
And for the public methods, the
setters and getters, they
grab the point represented by
the local view to the reducer
that it contains.
And it calls the method that
you called on that point.
So the question is what
does this thing do,
the hyperpoint object?
Anybody have any wild guesses
at this point?
That's a no.
So OK.
Let's try using this code.
So to put the example
into perspective.
Suppose I have this artificially
contrived
function that takes an array of
100 points, and it tries to
do an in place reversal
of its elements.
So one way that it can
do that is you have a
global temporary point.
And you, at every step of the
iteration, first you step
through half of the list.
And then at every step of the
iteration, you copy the ith
element into the temporary
variable.
And then you set the ith from
the other end to the--
you swap the two.
And then you--
yeah, so if it is a
three-variable swap, I guess
is the simplest way
of explaining it.
It's a swap using a using
a temporary variable.
Anyone not get what that code
does, despite my attempts to
confuse you?
So as far as this space
complexity of this procedure,
really what it needs at minimum
is enough memory to
store the temporary point, and
then one register to use to
put in the temporary values.
You can think of a solution that
uses only one register to
update values within your
point structure.
And so let's suppose I want
to do this in parallel.
And so what I do is I call it
parallel reverse, and I
replace for with Cilk for.
So am I done?
What's wrong with my code?
AUDIENCE: Race.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
Well first it takes that much--
it takes the same
amount of space.
But there is a data race on
temp, because multiple threads
could be updating temp.
So now what I do is I replace
my point with a hyperpoint.
So now what does the
hyperpoint do?
So within each iteration of the
Cilk for loop, so if that
iteration has been-- if the
work of that iteration has
been stolen or spawned off.
Then the hyperobject, because
it has a reducer within it,
it'll get a new local
view which is a new
point object to use.
And if it's not still in that
it continues running in the
same thread, then it actually
just continues using the local
view that was previously
instantiated.
So no matter what Cilk does
in the background, you're
guaranteed to not have any data
races on temp, because
whenever you spawn off a new
thread, the hyperobject will
instantiate a new temp object
for you to use.
And this is an example of what's
called thread local
storage, so like a temporary
storage space for each thread.
Any questions?
Cool.
So on the quiz, you might be
asked about various abusing of
various other novel hyperobjects
that don't do the
typical thing, which
is take a left and
right and reduce them.
They might do something
a little bit quirky.
And you might be asked to
explain what they do.
AUDIENCE: Maybe?
PROFESSOR: Yes?
Maybe.
AUDIENCE: But this is purely for
illustrating that you can
do such a thing with
hyperobjects.
Because you can always create
a temporary variable there.
PROFESSOR: But suppose point
was a much larger object.
Sure, this is a contrived
example.
But yes.
Anyone?
Everyone gets this?
So, in that case, why would that
problem be more efficient
than creating a new copy of
it, say another point?
PROFESSOR: Because if you think
about the case where
this code runs on a single
processor with no work
stealing, this version does the
exact same thing as the
single threaded version.
No extra objects are
being created.
And if you're running on however
many processors and
Cilk decides what to do in the
background as far as how many
threads to allocate for you, and
your code doesn't have to
know anything about that.
AUDIENCE: What's the
monoid again?
PROFESSOR: The monoid is the
associative operator that has
an identity and a reduce
operation and some other
things that I forgot.
Any more questions?
Cool.
So switching gears, and this
time I actually have a
placeholder slide for it, next
part is more about like the
types of things that you might
have learned from doing or
experience you might
have gained
from doing your projects.
And it primarily pertains to lab
oriented, like in practice
hands on things, as opposed
to theoretical concepts.
So just as a fun warm up,
everybody has hopefully at
this point used some
STL data structure.
Vectors should definitely
look familiar.
So let's compare some operations
on these three.
Because, as far as the API
is concerned, both list--
all three of them support
almost the same set of
functions, as far as Insert,
at pushback, pop front.
All those operations are
supported by these things.
So it's kind of--
You might ask why would you
use one over the other?
Well, it turns out that they
have slightly different
performance characteristics
that are useful in noting.
So anyone want to compare and
contrast like what data
structure a list corresponds
to compared to a vector?
So which one would be
like a linked list?
List, yep.
And then vector obviously is a
dynamically growing array.
And a deque--
how many people have
used the deque?
Cool.
One.
How many people know what
deque does even if they
haven't used it?
Three?
Four?
OK.
So a deque is actually
implemented similar to a
vector, but it's dynamically
growing on both ends.
OK, so let's start with
filling in the
table for the list.
So inserting and removing
at the end of a list.
Constant time?
Linear time?
How many people say
constant time?
Linear?
Half and half, wow.
Don't rely on your neighbor
during the test.
So it's actually
constant time.
If you think about appending to
the end of a linked list,
it's just a matter of couple
pointer operations.
How about inserting and
removing at the front?
Constant?
Cool.
Linear?
OK.
I'll stop picking
on people now.
So next is inserting and
removing an arbitrary offset.
So what I mean by that is you
have an iterator to a
particular point inside
the list.
Now I say insert this element
five or n elements away from
that iterator.
How long does that
operation take?
How many people say
constant time?
Three people.
How many people say some
sort of linear time?
I agree with you guys.
It is indeed a linear
time thing,
because you have to traverse--
you have to actually fall the
next pointers to the location
or the previous pointers
to the location
that you want to insert.
So although list might appear
to support randomish axis,
like you can add numbers to
the iterator, it doesn't
actually support that operation
efficiently in the
background.
Now the next one is also
kind of tricky.
Checking the size.
Like checking how many elements
are calling the dot
size method of a
standard list.
How many people think
that's constant?
Cool.
About four or five.
How many people think
that's linear?
One.
How many people think it's
possible to have a linked list
data structure that's forced
constant time?
There we go.
Well, unfortunately, the STL
only requires you to have a
big O of n time for this.
In fact, I peeked inside the
code for glibc the lib
standard C++ that is used
on the cloud machines.
And in fact, what they do is
they actually walk through
everything from start to
end, and they count up
the number of times.
So in fact, it is a linear time
operation, although I'm
sure somewhere out in the
world, there exists a C
library, C++ library that does
linear time, or constant time,
size look ups.
So you might want to be careful
about that one.
On a different note, there's
actually a dot empty method
for checking whether or not a
list is empty, and for any
type of STL collection
that is guaranteed
to be constant time.
So if you just want to know
whether something's empty,
don't use dot size equals 0.
What about reversing a
linked list in place?
Linear?
More than linear?
It's not a technical term, and
Charles is probably going to
hurt me now.
Linear?
Yes.
Linear.
What about in place sorting
of a linked list?
How many people think
it's N log(N)?
One or two daring souls.
Three daring souls.
A well informed daring soul.
How many people think it's
more than N log(N)?
One.
OK.
So actually it is N log(N).
And that's actually not
specified by the specs.
But it happens to be.
And it turns out that there is
a variant merge sort that
works on link list
that is N log(N).
I didn't know that,
but anyway.
So how about let's fill this
in for the vector.
Inserting and removing an
element at the end--
constant time?
Linear time?
Nobody says linear time.
So it's amortized constant
time, I guess.
I'll just call it
constant time.
What about inserting
or removing at
the front of a vector--
constant time?
Linear time?
Come on, guys.
I'm getting like three hands for
linear time and zero for
constant time.
I guess that's reasonable.
So it does, in fact,
insert one element.
It puts the element in and then
it grows the vector in.
It copies everything in.
So don't insert at the front,
don't insert or remove at the
front of a vector.
It's a very bad idea if
you do that a lot.
What about inserting or removing
at an arbitrary
location inside a vector?
Well, that one's fairly obvious
to be some sort of
linear time too, because it
has to shift all of the
elements after it.
Checking the size
of the vector?
Some people are getting
pessimistic about the STL.
That's my personal opinion,
but I won't
transfer that onto you.
So it turns out that for a
vector, yes, it is constant
time to check the size.
So that's OK.
In place reversal,
linear time.
And sorting is N log(N),
which is not
surprising by any means.
So a deque?
Inserting or removing
at the end--
constant?
Sure, constant.
And inserting or removing
at the front?
Cool.
Constant.
So that's the primary
difference between
a deque and a vector.
And for everything else, it
behaves exactly like a vector.
Does that makes sense?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: So is list like
a doubly linked list?
PROFESSOR: A standard list is in
fact a doubly linked list.
So it supports both forward
and reverse traversal.
There's a standard S list, which
is a singly linked list,
and it only supports
forward traversal.
Any other questions?
Moving on to a slightly
different topic, can anyone
point out what is bad
about this code?
And I mean from a performance
standpoint.
AUDIENCE: It's O of n.
PROFESSOR: All right.
Someone said it,
so it's O of n.
So the vector that's passed in
here is passed in by value,
which means whenever you call
this function, it'll actually
make a brand new copy
of the vector and
copy all of the elements.
So it's linear time with respect
to the number of
elements in the vector.
PROFESSOR: So how
do you fix that?
AUDIENCE: You can pass
in a pointer.
PROFESSOR: So there's
two ways.
So on the left is the original
code, and on the right are two
different ways to pass in just
a pointer to the same thing.
So you can do a reference
pass, which is the first
version above.
And then you can use a dot
to access the methods.
Or you can pass in by pointer
which everyone is already
familiar with.
And that's where you
have to use arrows
to access the elements.
And then you also have to change
the way that you call
the function.
So oftentimes if you just catch
something in code, like
say the final project where
something is passed by value,
where it should be passed by
reference, oftentimes the
easiest way to modify the code
is to just change it to use a
reference rather
than a pointer.
So the next thing that I want
to cover is a question type
that will be on the final,
will be on the quiz.
And I'll give some examples
of problems of this form.
But most importantly, I want
everybody to be familiar with
the form of the question, the
rules involving the question,
so nobody accidentally loses
points for not reading the
instructions, which nobody
seems to do on quizzes.
So you are given two versions
of the same function written
in C or C++.
And you are to assume
that your compiler--
well, the compiler, as far as
like what the CPU is executing
is a literal interpretation
of the code you
see before and after.
By this point, everybody is
probably familiar with some of
the simple tricks a compiler
does, like if you say int x
equals 1 plus 1 there is no
circumstance in which the
compiler actually puts two 1s in
two different registers and
tells it to add it and
then put it in x.
So you are assuming that your
compiler is doing a literal
translation.
And then you are asked to
determine three properties
about the optimization,
so going from the
before to the after.
So the first thing is
whether or not the
optimization is legal.
And when we define legal, we
mean that the optimized
version always has the same--
preserves the same behavior
as the other version.
It should be relatively simple
to infer from the code
snippets that we give you, what
the intended purpose of a
function is.
And you are to determine whether
or not the optimized
version acts like the
unoptimized version, as far as
the correctness of the result.
Second, you are asked to
determine whether or not this
optimized version is faster
than the previous version.
And by faster, we mean faster
in most conceivable cases.
It's a short answer question so
you might want to explain
what you mean.
But we do expect a yes
or no answer to
start off the question.
And it should be pretty
clear whether the
answer is yes or no.
And then finally, I'm sure by
this point everybody knows
that when you compile with gcc
-02 or -03, the compiler does
a lot of things for you.
So there's oftentimes no point
in writing certain
optimizations by hand, when
you know when you hit the
compile button, the compiler's
going to do it in the
background anyway.
So this question asks whether
or not you can reasonably
assume that the optimizing
compilers, like the ones that
you're using for your projects,
would do this
optimization for you or should
you take the effort to
actually do this optimization
by hand.
And then, legalese, if the
optimization is illegal, let's
not answer whether or not it's
faster or automatic.
And if the optimization actually
makes things slower,
then let's not answer whether
the compiler does it for you.
Some of us have more cynical
views of the
compiler than others.
So we'll just disregard that.
Any question on the rules?
AUDIENCE: How are we supposed
to know what types of things
the compiler's going to do,
can we just read the
documentation?
PROFESSOR: So there was a
lecture that Samaan gave
called What Compilers
Can and Cannot Do.
AUDIENCE: So it's just stuff
from that lecture?
PROFESSOR: I would say most
of it is that lecture.
And then other things-- we might
throw in a thing or two
that you guys hopefully
learn from.
So throughout the term, we've
been misguiding you on those
walk through P-sets, suggesting
you to do things
that actually don't help.
And you guys have gotten
pretty pissed at
us about that probably.
But there was a method
to the madness.
I mean, there was something to
be learned from that, whether
or not we actually
meant to do it.
So hopefully some level of
intuition would answer it, and
you would get the bulk of the
points for just understanding
the points raised
in the lecture.
Any other questions
about the rules?
All right.
So I have a couple of examples
of these types of questions.
So the first one is this.
So it should be fairly obvious
what the code does.
It takes your input, and it
wants to mod it by 256.
So first question is this
a legal optimization?
How many people say yes?
A lot of people.
Anybody say no?
Reed almost scared me
for a moment there.
He had his hand up.
So yes, it is indeed legal.
And it's a standard bit hack
for doing a modulo
by a power of two.
AUDIENCE: What if it's 257?
PROFESSOR: I was fortunate
enough to make it a uint64.
So next question is given that
it's legal, is it faster to do
the and instead of the mod?
How many people say yes?
How many people say no?
So a majority of the
class says yes, and
some people say no.
So what would be a reason why
you think it's not faster?
AUDIENCE: Well, I didn't say
it's not faster faster.
It's probably the same time,
because I assume the
instruction for modding is not
actually dividing by it.
PROFESSOR: So for the other
people who said no, how many
people agree with that
line of reasoning?
All right.
Seems like everybody.
So unfortunately,
it is faster.
And it turns out, I compiled
down both of these pieces of
code under-- well, actually,
the compiler--
but anyway, I'll get
to that next.
Not giving away any answers.
But so I executed the assembly
instructions corresponding to
both of these operations.
And it does turn out that the
compiler, the CPU, when you
ask it to take the mod of an
arbitrary number, usually it's
an instruction called div mod.
And what that does is that it
does a divided by b, and it
puts the dividend in one
register and it puts the
modulo in another register.
And we do that for, let's say,
2 to the 63rd modulo 256,
because it actually goes through
all the clock cycles
for doing that division
process.
And then it dumps out the
modulo at the end.
So yes, this actually does
tend to be a lot faster.
Now next question is will the
compiler do this for you?
How many people say yes?
Most of the class.
Anybody say no?
Good.
We all trust the compiler
to some extent.
So yeah, it turns out that gcc,
starting from 01, will do
this for you.
Any questions?
All right.
Next question.
So you have a list.
And you pushed in.
You pushed at the end.
It's 42, twice.
And then you returned the result
of popping the front
element and then popping the
back element, subtracted.
So first of all, is this
a legal operation?
Let me give everybody
a chance to think.
AUDIENCE: Legal optimization
as opposed to an operation.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
How many people vote yes,
this is going legal?
Roughly half the class.
How many people say no,
this is not legal?
Two people.
OK, so why would it
not be legal?
You can't do that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: There happens to be
wastefulness on some problems.
PROFESSOR: Well, that could
certainly happen.
But for the purpose of
these problems--
see this is why I'm bringing up
these problems-- so for the
purpose of these problems,
assume there's no man behind
the curtain doing things.
For any given problem, you
could say that's someone
attaching a debugger to your
program and changing the
memory between instructions.
So let's just assume
that's happening.
AUDIENCE: Also, who's
local, right?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Yea, Foo is actually local,
so if anybody else's doing
anything to it, they're
a very bad person.
So fine.
It's a legal optimization.
Now.
is it faster?
How many people think that
returning zero is slower than
pushing two things up?
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Depends upon
how big zero is.
PROFESSOR: That's true.
So OK, so yes, obviously,
it's faster to just
directly return zero.
And finally, is this an
automatic optimization?
How many people say yes?
Cool.
Nobody said yes.
How many people say no?
People who say yes, if you
could work for compiler
companies, I would appreciate
that a lot.
So unfortunately, the compiler
does not make--
cannot reason through how an
STL list works, and realize
that what you're doing
is an no op.
It turns out that for a related
set of questions, like
have any of your mentors said
anything to-- so my mentor
said this to me last year.
And I was pretty interested
when I tried it out.
Have you ever used a for loop to
set everything in an array
to equals 0?
Most people seem to
have done that.
Who has used the memset or heard
of the memset set API
call before?
A good portion of the class.
OK, so some people.
So a little bit of
background then.
Mem set instruction takes in an
array or a pointer rather,
and a constant, and the
size of the array.
And it sets that many elements
of the array to that constant.
So it turns out that depending
on the machine that you're
using, there is more efficient
and less efficient ways of
setting all the elements
of an array to 0.
And functions like mem set are
actually are several pages
long of hand optimized assembly
to be optimal for
your architecture.
So it's always tempting to take
a for loop that iterates
through an array, setting
everything to 0, and changing
it to a single mem
set instruction.
And it turns out that for both
gcc and icc, Intel C compiler,
when you compile at sufficient
optimization level, the
compiler actually does
this for you.
It actually looks through
the arrays.
It actually realizes that you're
setting all the members
in the array to a constant, and
it does that optimization
for you by replacing it
with a memset call.
So just as a general question,
why could it be advantageous
for you to write the four loop
as is, and have the compiler
do the optimization for you?
AUDIENCE: Because you later
might add code in the loop.
PROFESSOR: True.
Any other reasons?
PROFESSOR: I didn't
hear question.
PROFESSOR: You might want to
add code that changes the
behavior inside the loop.
AUDIENCE: It's much more
readable to have a for loop
and you just read it, and I get
that's what he's doing.
PROFESSOR: Yes, indeed.
Looking over some of your code
submissions, it seems to be a
non-trivial task of figuring out
the size of something when
you call malloc or memset.
And actually, it sometimes is
a non-trivial operation to
figure out how big something
is in bytes, especially for
structs and things like that.
So it actually is easier to
let the compiler do the
optimization for you, and you
don't make any embarrassing
mistakes in the process.
So next question.
So here you have a
helper function.
And in the after version,
seems to do the
same thing, does it?
So who thinks this is a
legal optimization?
Half the class.
Anyone think it's illegal?
So yeah, it is legal.
The only thing that I've done
is that I've copy pasted
basically the function body
in the bottom example.
And it's relatively easy to
prove that or infer that the
two do the same thing.
So is it faster?
How many people say yes?
How many people say no?
One person said no.
Why is it not faster?
AUDIENCE: I mean, I've said
that it is the same speed,
because so the only thing that
would make it slower would be
the-- you need to actually
do like a compass switch.
Because you need to call that
function every time.
But I think it could provide
the concept for you-- like
basically, it's a
static function.
It would inline it even though
you don't have to declare it.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So if you recall the rules for
the question, so basically we
want you to interpret the
code, as is, like a very
literal interpretation as in--
the point was raised that for
this function call, what you
actually want to do is assume
that the compiler is setting
up a function called by putting
the arguments in the
right register and jumping
to the address of
that function above.
So for the case of this-- for
the matter-- for the purpose
of this question, yes, it's
much faster to just do a
multiply compared to setting up
a call stack and tearing it
down after the function
is done.
Now the next question is is this
automatic, which was more
or less answered.
And that's yes.
So at a sufficient optimization
level which is
-03 or -02 with dash f inline
functions, the compiler will
actually use a heuristic that it
has for determining whether
or not a function is a good
candidate for inlining.
And for good candidates, it'll
do the inlining for you.
Now the specific
heuristics vary
from compiler to compiler.
But for this specific problem
that we gave you, it's a prime
candidate for inlining, because
it's declared as
static, which means it's
local to this C file.
And it does a very simple
task, a one-liner, so it
almost certainly will
be inline for you.
Any questions?
Cool.
So this one.
Question?
AUDIENCE: I don't get it.
Could you explain again?
I know I've asked this
before, like what's
static, the static function?
And it's different
than in Java?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So the question was what's a
static function in C. And so
in C, a static function means
when you declare a function as
static, it means that the
function is local to the
current file that you're work--
the current module, the
dot-o file, which is almost
always your dot-c file.
So like the function only exists
within this dot-c file.
A function in another
dot-c file
cannot call this function.
So it basically allows the
compiler to assume that
there's no external effects on
this function that are not
within this file.
Remember the compiler compiles
object files one by one, and
then the linker is the one that
brings it all together.
AUDIENCE: So the important thing
is that it knows that it
can just delete helper after
it's gotten rid of it.
PROFESSOR: Right, right.
That's another good point.
So in this case, after inlining,
the compiler
actually won't bother to put in
the function helper inside
the actual object file.
So you save on my code space.
Because the compiler knows
that nowhere else this
function can be called.
AUDIENCE: What about
static in C++?
PROFESSOR: Static in C++ when
used inside a class means that
the function is a static
member function.
So it's a function that's tied
to the class itself, rather
than an object, and instance
of the class.
AUDIENCE: Just like Java.
PROFESSOR: Just like Java.
More questions?
Cool.
So back to this code.
First of all, is anyone not
familiar with the syntax or
wants the syntax explained?
OK, cool.
So first question,
is it legal?
How may people say yes?
Half the class.
How many people say no.
Roughly half the class.
Well, I and the people grading
the quiz will side with the
people who say no, because down
here when you're doing--
this is the correct version
of the XOR swap.
I'm not trying to trick
anyone there.
But it turns out--
well, I'd rather not assume
that t, the arbitrary type
name, has an operator XOR
defined for it that has all
the properties that you need
in order for it to do this.
Like the simplest example is
if I pass in a double, this
would not work.
Double does not have an operator
XOR defined for it.
Some people look upset.
AUDIENCE: [LAUGHTER]
PROFESSOR: A list too
would not have an
XOR defined for it.
Anyone disagree with me?
That's not a challenge.
So yeah, some of these questions
require you to do a
little bit of reasoning, like
reasonable reasoning, as far
as what to assume for the
purposes of the question.
So watch out for that.
So in this case, it's not legal,
so you don't have to
answer the next two questions.
So OK.
So let's fix this.
And by fix it, I mean
not use templates.
So now we're just operating
on ints.
And ints do have the proper
operator XOR that has all the
good properties that you want.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What's the and
notation of the variable.
PROFESSOR: It's a reference.
So it's a reference to it.
Because you need references,
because you actually want to
swap the two items that
are being called in.
Right?
AUDIENCE: Can you use
like pointeres?
PROFESSOR: Yes, so you can also
use a pointer for it.
Pointers and references, C
will treat this use of
references the same way as
if you use pointers.
So references are
syntactic sugar.
And what it basically allows you
to do is write code that
looks like you're operating on
standard intervals, standard
integers, but in fact that it's
a pointer to the value
that the name of the variable
that's passed in here.
Otherwise this code would be
riddled with a bunch of stars.
Now is this legal?
How many people say yes?
Most of the class.
How many people say no?
One person.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If A and B are
the same variable,
you set it to zero.
PROFESSOR: Yes, exactly.
The XOR law has a nasty side
effect where you want to make
sure that A and B are not
the same variable.
Not they don't contain the
same-- they can contain the
same value in different
variables, but they can't be
the same variable or the
same register or
the same memory location.
Otherwise, when you do A equals
Ax or B, that's 0.
And now both A and
B point to 0.
And there's nothing you can do
to get your old value back.
AUDIENCE: Can you check
for equivalence of
recordkeeping in C++.
PROFESSOR: Indeed, you can.
If you take the address of the
reference, it gives you the
address of the original value.
So this would be the proper
way, I guess, of
doing an XOR swap.
So now that we've gotten over
all the trick questions, is
this actually faster?
How many people say yes?
One, two, three, four.
How many people say no?
Cool.
Most of the class.
So this is another example
of a gray area question.
So in this class, we primarily
talk about the cloud machines,
as far as the performance
analysis that we've done.
So on the cloud machines, and
this was mentioned in
Charles's bit hacks lecture
which was, well, the second
lecture in the course.
This trick is not faster
on the cloud machines.
Because what you end up doing
is you create a lot of
dependencies between these
operands, so that the pipeline
must execute these one
by one serially.
So you introduce a lot
of delays by that.
And plus now that we actually
want you to write a correct
program, you have to
do this check, and
that's an extra branch.
And finally these XORs have to
be done by the ALU, and up to
five execution ports.
Only three of them are ALUs.
The other two can do memory
operations just fine.
So it turns out that for a
combination of these reasons,
this version indeed with the
temporary register actually
does run faster.
Any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: For branches, we
assume advanced features, like
it will preload the exceptions
and only invalidates the thing
when certain branches fail.
PROFESSOR: Sure, you can assume
cool properties about
the chip, such as speculative
execution,
prefetching, and so on.
But the problem is those tricks
are fine when you're
doing things sparsely as in
you're sometimes doing work
and other times not
doing work.
But like speculative execution,
like when you
execute both sides of a branch,
you're using more or
less double your execution
or resources.
And if you have all processors
running some intense piece of
code that's doing swapping,
you don't have any extra
resources to dedicate towards
running code that
might not be useful.
Any other questions?
Cool.
So finally, I got tired
of making slides.
Well, actually that's
not true.
It's more I'd rather concentrate
the slides on
things that I think are more
useful than other things, as
far as per preparation
for your quiz.
All your time is valuable.
And so there's other topics
that are fair game for the
quiz, because they've been
mentioned in lectures up to
this point.
But I haven't prepared
any slides on them.
And the fractal trees were
covered by the guest lecture
by Bradley.
And the slides are up.
I suggest familiarizing yourself
with the basic
workings of how the data
structure that
he described works.
And lock free data structures
were covered on your take home
P set, and also in a lecture.
So be prepared to
answer potential
questions about that.
And then finally the mechanism
behind the Cilk runtime, the
work stealing scheduler, how
it's implemented on the Linux
side, and also the basics of
what a Cilk hyperobject is,
what a Cilk hyperobject
has to have.
Advantages and disadvantages
of using them and so on.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Are the grades
for the P-set out?
PROFESSOR: No, they
are not out yet.
AUDIENCE: Are there solutions
for the P-set?
PROFESSOR: Not yet.
But I believe we have something
prepared for that, right?
Somewhat?
Yeah, it's somewhat prepared.
If you have any questions about
like questions on the
pset that you want answer to,
feel free to stop by office
hours or email us and
we can help you.
Yeah, apologies for not
getting that P set
back to you in time.
Any other questions relating
to the quiz.
It's really all the material
I have as far as reviewing.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are you going to
put these slides up?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I'll
put these slides up
right after the lecture.
So as far as a general notes,
I guess you guys turned in
your finals yesterday, and you
guys have a design report that
you also turned in.
Your POSSE members should have
contacted you by now, as far
as scheduling a design
review session.
Since this project is actually
due on next Thursday, it might
be a good idea to get this done
by the end of the week.
Otherwise, the design
review won't be
a very useful process.
AUDIENCE: There are a couple of
students without a mentor
right now here.
We are fixing that.
PROFESSOR: Right.
There's a couple of students
caught in limbo right now.
Sorry about that.
PROFESSOR: If you were--
previously dropped on Stellar,
send us an email.
If you haven't been to drop
through this course, there are
no longer drops allowed.
Yeah,
AUDIENCE: So it's your
responsibility.
I'm going to put
on my mean hat.
It's your responsibility to
schedule a meeting with your
POSSE member, and make sure
that it happens by
the end of the week.
And if it doesn't look like
it's going to happen, or
you're having difficulties
getting in touch with your
mentor, or you don't have one
yet, please drop us an email
or come by office hours and
make sure that we know.
All right.
That's it.